what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
all right Rob core we are in a weird
situation then the reason why is because
of the fact that we are continuing to
cover the Omega and Beyond Omega level
series the problem with this is I want
to start rolling things over into like
DC and valiant and image the issue is
that almost all publishers outside of
Marvel have no classification for their
characters so we can do one of two
things either we can keep the Omega and
Beyond the Omega level name going which
I'd prefer to do and then just tech
characters on so like Beyond Omega level
Superman 1 million or you know Omega
level superboy-prime
or something along those lines at the
same time we could just rename it
because remember the designation Omega
and Beyond Omega level is either
established by virtue of somebody else
referring to them that way or just
because of the level of power they
possess for example storm was classified
as an Omega level threat by symbols
meaning she's now in omega-level mutant
that was done in Black Panther number 21
I think it was or 17 or something along
those lines but with characters like
protege for example he's not really
listed as an Omega level being per se
but because of the power that he
possesses he's well beyond Omega level
and almost every single former fashion
so again it's really up to you I mean
just supposed to comment down below and
let me know what you guys think I'd
rather keep the Omega level name going
but if we have to rename it then we can
but anyway protege is probably the most
overpowered character that I've ever
seen uh that's not a mutant keep in mind
the marquee of death when it comes to
like mutants like the whole mutant
roster the marquee of death was about as
powerful as we as we came across but
with characters like protege is
absolutely insane because it's power
it's actually pretty unique so all this
really stems back to Adam warlock Adam
warlock of course being a character
who's been around for quite some time
it's basically like Jesus in men model
comics I mean he's been crucified he's
died he's been resurrected
I mean he's effectively Jesus for all
intents and purposes and he's had some
pretty cool moments I'm curious to see
what they're going to do with him in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe as far as I'm
aware he's not going to be an infinity
war but it'll wake him up early and
he'll be an Infinity Gauntlet I have no
clue but Adam warlock actually had an
evil persona that was called The Magus
but the way this played out is Adam
warlock received his infinity stone from
the High Evolutionary you know Adam
warlock out the soul stone and over the
course of his publication history it was
revealed that at some point in the
future Adam warlock was going to become
a bad guy named The Magus which is
basically where he became corrupted by
his own infinity stone now of course
this led into all kinds of time travel
capers and different things like that
where Adam warlock effectively kept this
from happening but there is an alternate
reality called Earth 691 where this
didn't happen where the Magus basically
became a villain that's one of the
reasons why the Magus always ends up
coming back now in the in this
particular reality and even in the
future of the main model universe the
Magus started a religious organization
called the universal Church of truth and
the universal Church of truth simply
just existed to consolidate power that's
all it was it was conquering
civilizations it was conquering planets
at the height of its rule the universal
Church of truth encompassed billions of
people across you know millions of star
systems and it was absolutely crazy how
huge it was that was one of the things
that we saw during the Thanos imperative
storyline when the rift was torn open in
space the universal Church of truth
teleported all these different ships and
all these different planets along the
Rift and then blew them all up toward
the rift open and in the cancerverse
started spilling out it was really kind
of a cool set of stories there but in
this particular instance in the earth
six nine one reality The Magus was
effectively defeated and then eliminated
as so the result was that the universal
Church of truth had no leader and so
what they did is they basically created
their own God in the form of a kid named
protege now because of the fact that
this is all you know totally separate
from the main Marvel Universe things
unfolded pretty interesting and in a
pretty wild way and it had its own
iteration of secret Wars and so on and
so forth but the idea here is that
eventually the Beyonder stumbles across
Protege and actually kidnaps protege
just to kind of see what what the kids
about and that's when protegees powers
start manifesting what we end up finding
out is that this kid has the ability to
duplicate the powers of others and
there's no limit to it as long as you
see the person using their powers then
he can basically duplicate them in any
form or fashion the first time this
happens is against the Beyonder the
Beyonder starts to use these reality
working hours and then protege starts
mimicking them and then overpowers the
Beyonder and defeats him now because of
the fact of the Beyonder was defeated by
protege in return The Living Tribunal
saw everything that was happening and
considered the you know consider Protege
to be this imbalanced in the multiverse
meaning that if he was allowed to live
long enough protege could potentially
conquer the entirety of the multiverse
and become the new one above all the
funny thing about this is that protege
began to realize that him
so and so the result is that he just
sorted hopping around to all these
different villains all these different
heroes all these different high-level
cosmic entities eternity and so on and
so forth and started battling all of
them for the purpose of basically seeing
what they were capable of copying their
powers keeping those powers defeating
them and then going forward as this just
godlike powerful being now keep in mind
protege only appeared for something like
14 issues or something along those lines
it was for a singular story arc but what
this did is it also coincided with the
guardians of the galaxy from the 31st
century so again them arriving on the
scene was really more like a stopgap
measure there wasn't a whole lot they
could do and if doc protege actually
intended to conquer the entire realm of
the beyonders and that's what makes
Protege so powerful despite the fact
that these beings had an insane level of
power if he sees them use those powers
he can duplicate it and that's the
inherent weakness that he has he can't
actually use the powers that another
person has until he sees them using
their powers now if a person were to
used telepathy on him and he would have
realized they were using telepathy then
suddenly he's a telepath if a person has
the ability to manipulate matter on the
subatomic scale and he sees them doing
that now he can do it and this led all
the way up to the Living Tribunal and so
that's what makes him one of the most
dangerous characters is because the
living tribunal had the battle protege
but every conflict every single attack
that the Living Tribunal used Protege
was immediately able to duplicate it to
overcome it as the result was that
protege was in effect as powerful as the
one above all now the only way in which
Marvel could basically write themselves
out of this hole that they created was
to try to find a workaround for
defeating protege if protege couldn't be
beat through traditional means where
just to say a straight-up fight then
protege basically had to be trick and so
what Marvel did is they introduced a
celestial named escape and the approver
and they basically gave no information
about this guy there was absolutely
nothing to indicate what skatin was
about or what skatin was capable of or
what he could do all we knew was it's
Kate and was either in approver or
disapprove or either he agreed with what
was happening or he didn't agree with
what was happening we don't know if
skates in the approver was the one above
all we don't know if skates in the
approver was just this insanely powerful
celestial more powerful than anything
else you know we don't know if it was on
par with like the dreaming celestial or
something along those lines those you
guys who read that x-men store
for those of you guys who don't know the
dreaming celestial is like the most
powerful celestial to have ever existed
like all the other Celestials are
terrified of it they actually locked
them away on earth for quite some time
but the vacuum ain't here that what is
up happening in this story escaping the
approver disapproves of what it is the
Protege is doing by basically attacking
every single cosmic entity and a living
tribunal and the Celestials and these
superheroes and defeating them all at
the same time and in return The Living
Tribunal uses its power to basically
confine Protege and keep them locked
away to basically absorb protege into
themselves and so again it's kind of a
in run to defeat his character is kind
of a way to just sort of throw it out
you know and not have to really worry
about it but at is absolute peak when
protege was at his absolute highest
point in power he was the most powerful
being to have ever existed in the
history of Marvel Comics as far as I'm
aware powerful than any mutant we've
ever seen more powerful than the Living
Tribunal second only to the one above
all and even then that asks the question
could Protege become as powerful as the
one above all assuming to the one above
all had enough power to just phase
protege out of existence without Protege
realizing the one above all was there
then that would bring it into the
conflict pretty quickly no muss no fuss
but as we know from previous stories the
one above all works in weird ways for
example during the story Marvel the end
when Thanos destroyed the entirety of
the multiverse it was because the one
above all realized that there was a
imbalance or an incorrect aspect of the
multiverse and in turn instigated a
series of events that led to Thanos
discovery the heart of the universe
absorbing that power into itself and
then when Thanos realized what was going
on
fixing the imbalance which basically
just turned out to be everybody
effectively dying and then following
that effectively killed himself off but
despite all this stuff if Protege can
copy the powers of people that he sees
or individuals who use these different
powers if the one above all were to step
in and protege were to see the one above
all using these reality-warping powers
or something along those lines he would
instantly be able to counter those
abilities and then probably overpower
the one above all or at the very least
the battle would lead to a stalemate
that would obliterate all things in
existence would literally destroy the
entire omniverse of Marvel which is a
concept that we haven't even dealt with
yet the omniverse those you guys who
don't know encompasses everything like
that's the movies the TV shows the
comics even the real world so to speak
that's the kind of
or that you know the one wall wall has
and it would lead to the destruction of
all those things like marble would
simply cease to exist you know if they
were to write that story that's how the
writer would play it out they would say
and now all things in existence are gone
that's how that story would end but
that's the kind of power that we're
dealing with here with protégé its
unrivaled I've never seen anything like
this I mean there's no character out
there that could conceivably stand
toe-to-toe against protege in terms of
just straight-up use of their abilities
but without being said guys we're gonna
go ahead and bring this video to and and
feel free to leave a comment down below
let me know what you think we should do
with the future of the Omega beyond
Omega level name rolling in other
characters publications different things
like that if you're new here the
comments explained make sure you get the
sub button to become part of the rob
Court you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later
you
[Applause]
[Music]